et j'ai résolu beaucoup d'enquêtes avec
elle
dit on va dans mon passage secret on va
récupérer des chevaux et on attaque les
Allemands
comment ça
bah le livre que j'ai écrit
ok tu te sers de mon livre pour faire le
mécanisme d'ouverture de ta cachette
secrète ouais ok
super je les ai gardé où
dans une pochette plastique elle est où
la pochette plastique dans ma
bibliothèque
dans ta bibliothèque elle est où tu l'as
rangée où elle est où non
ma bibliothèque de ma maison à Biarritz
n'importe quoi de quoi n'importe quoi si
j'ai une maison à berbis pourquoi je
vois pas de maison Biarritz je fais du
surf j'adore le surf tu peux demander à
Bernardo
bah non regarde il nous écoute pas
en tout cas je trouve ça vraiment pas
sympa je trouve ça se fait trop pas ce
que tu as fait en plus je me rappelle
très bien c'est un livre que je t'avais
dédicacé j'avais fait un peu un
personnalisé pour toi un truc qui touche
vraiment sur sur les chevaux ok ok donc
on se dit tout on dit qu'on se dit tout
ok donc quand j'ai fait ce passage
secret je me suis dit il faut que je
prenne un livre qui actionne le
mécanisme que personne ne lit OK et le
livre que personne ne lit bah c'est ton
livre voilà je suis désolé c'est ton
livre et en plus tes poèmes
ok ben normal donc vu que c'est de la
prose donc c'est normal que ça aime pas
donc voilà
en tout cas très sympa super sympa super
ambiance ok on dit qu'on oublie et on
prend un autre passage secret d'accord
OK
ah d'accord
quoi